okay so spoiler-free review for the
batman by matt reeves right not going to
spoil anything in this video uh the only
thing i will say is there is a
post-credits scene so make sure you guys
stay for that but uh but the movie is
really really good so i imagine the
first thing people are going to ask here
is how does this movie compare
to like the dark knight by christopher
nolan um or even movies like the marvel
cinematic universe so those movies that
come out the reality is it feels
different you know what this movie feels
a lot like it feels a lot like the joker
movie that's really what it feels more
like than anything else it feels like a
a highly dramatic hollywood film that
happens to feature a comic book
character now i'm not saying that
because it's a bad thing the joker is
probably the single greatest comic book
movie that i think i've ever seen the
movie was absolutely phenomenal i loved
it uh this movie was great if this is
really the form and function of the
future of comic book movies at least
from warner brothers
then they got it man because here's the
thing i've been saying for a long long
time as much as the the dc cinematic
universe or what passes for the dc
cinematic universe is in shambles and
has been right for a long time that
includes scott snyder for all you snyder
fans who believe he never does anything
wrong uh it's it's it's rough right it's
bad like the dc cinematic universe they
don't know what it is like it's just
it's all over the place this right here
this movie needs to be the future of the
dc cinematic universe it's what their
movies need to feel like now of course a
superman movie needs to be more hopeful
than a batman movie but like the batman
movie feeling like the joker movie goes
hand in hand and is perfect right it's
absolutely perfect the way that it's
done having said that
the movie was longer than it needed to
be honestly three hours was way too long
for this movie i found myself kind of
looking at my watch and just kind of
being like all right let's let's
let's wrap this up right i wanted to
break out the uh the wrap it up box from
from chappelle show back in the day if
you guys remember that skit uh i was
kind of feeling that way once we got
around to like the two hour to the two
hour 10 2 hour 15 minute mark i was like
okay it's time to start wrapping this up
three hours was much too long um
honestly two hours would have been great
but even during that three hours by the
time we got to the end of it it was kind
of like
you know but the whole detective element
i feel like is really what made this
film what made this stand apart right
here's the thing what made this movie
stand apart from so many other batman
movies is it didn't feel like a comic
book story arc it basically was right
and the the ending of the movie
certainly is setting up for one of the
most popular comic book story arcs to
ever come out of batman in recent years
but nonetheless right it is it didn't it
didn't feel like a comic book storyline
it felt like a detective noir film that
happened to feature batman you could
have put anybody in that role right you
could have taken anybody you could
remove batman and put virtually anybody
else in there and it would have fit just
fine the fact that it's batman just
really sort of adds to it because i feel
like in a lot of ways that's what's
missing from the various batman films
that have been made in recent years as
much as we all love christopher nolan's
dark knight trilogy
even then it felt very fantasy which
makes sense batman is a fictional
character this movie felt grounded and
tangible and real it felt like an actual
thing like the city of gotham does
actually exist out there and this guy is
basically fighting crime in the city of
gotham the other cool thing about this
and this is something that i absolutely
loved the most nine times out of ten in
almost every single instance when we see
a batman movie you basically see him
just very very capable even in batman
begins by christopher nolan right like
he was able to basically pick up the
ropes on how to be batman like that
right it happened so quickly and this
one the movie is basically him just
figuring out how to be batman and it's
great because he's unpolished he doesn't
have like the best fighting style ever
he doesn't counter and parry every
single attack perfectly he gets hit
multiple times there's a few times where
he's like damn is he gonna make it i
loved that right because while the
batman that i expect to see uh robert
pattinson become is like the polished
batman right the batman who's just like
i know how to counter every single
attack and i can fight 50 people all at
once and not get touched one time while
we all expect him to become that version
of batman uh he's not there yet and it's
cool to kind of follow this journey of a
guy who is in effect becoming the batman
character and watch him fail and watch
him screw up and watch him get things
wrong right to basically get the wrong
clue when he should have gotten the
right clue and so on and so forth it's
cool right it's a great concept in terms
of how they build the character the
other part of this and you guys have
seen it in the trailer the batmobile is
lit oh my god dude that thing is amazing
it's just god it just screams i'm gonna
[ __ ] you up like just the sound of the
car right just the sound of the car oh
and one more other thing about batman
the times when he shows up now when he
comes like swooping in from like the
roof like the moments right when like
somebody's somewhere's robbing someone
else and you expect him like come out of
the shadows it's a slow thing but it's
like damn like like there was one point
and not a huge spoiler here but there
was one point where like some things
were popping off and batman just slowly
shows up and i was like man
somebody's about to get [ __ ] up
it was really cool right it was a really
really really cool thing but again the
batmobile is just great right it's just
it just it's it it feels basic it feels
primitive it feels like he's not really
at the point where he has like the super
high-end batmobile but just something
about that sound man just like this jet
powered muscle car the really cool thing
about this too is it really does have
hints of like christopher nolan's dark
knight trilogy in terms of the
supporting cast james gordon catwoman
it's not like one of those things where
like they're there and they're just
doing some things and you don't really
care about them no you do and there's
more than a few times when you're in
this movie and you're asking the
question like damn is jim gordon like a
bad guy like is he
is he is he shady like is he sketchy has
he been doing some things he's not like
you know that kind of thing right did
jim gordon get his hand caught in the
cookie jar that's the kind of question
you find yourself asking
and it's cool that they transformed jim
gordon from just this guy who's part of
the cops and is like batman's contact
into an actual character whose loyalties
and moral compass you actually question
the story of catwoman phenomenal no
spoilers there but absolutely amazing
the penguin let me tell you something
man
the penguin right there's there's a few
other characters in this movie i'm not
going to spoil any of them but there's
there's some other characters besides
the penguin in this movie you've only
been given like a small little sampling
of what's actually going on by looking
at the trailers which kudos to warner
brothers for that but the penguin wow he
was great i loved him he had so much
character and he and like colin farrell
i got to be honest man a lot of people
didn't know it was colin farrell who was
playing the penguin but like everybody's
gonna know now because the penguin was
such a cool character i feel like this
is colin farrell's comeback film man not
even gonna lie like i feel like this is
his comeback movie where he's not really
typecast anymore you guys remember like
swat movies like that that he did back
in the day where he was like that one
guy that always played the same role in
like every every single movie he ever
played the recruit i think with al
pacino was another example of that he
always played the same kind of guy this
one just feels different right he's got
depth he's got range the penguin to a
degree i wouldn't go as far as to say as
the guy that you're rooting for but by
the time you get to the end of the movie
you're kind of like yeah man i kind of
want to see what things look like with
the penguin now right he's just he's
fascinating and what's so interesting is
that in a lot of ways the penguin's kind
of a background character but despite
being a background character he's still
kind of in the forefront right so he's
not really a primary character but he's
not really a background character he's
just kind of somewhere in the middle so
as obvious as you watch those movies
that like they're building him up and
he's going to become something better uh
alfred pennyworth loved alfred
pennyworth you don't really see him all
that much but there is a phenomenal
dynamic between bruce wayne and alfred
pennyworth i love it right the
relationship is is the relationship
between two of them is great right it's
really really great i'll let you guys
see you know get a feel for it um but
it's it's great right it's just it's
great how the characters interact and
and all that kind of cool stuff now one
of the big things that people are
probably going to be asking here is
what's the pacing of the movie like is
it more boring than it is interesting
okay so there is the detective element
there is the whole element of him like
going through and examining clues and
different things like that i wouldn't go
as far as to say that it's boring i
would say that him investigating and
looking around and trying to understand
what's happening with regards to like
the crimes that are taking place and the
actions of the riddler and all that kind
of stuff uh that it is perfectly
balanced not perfectly but it's very
well balanced with like action sequences
and fight scenes so it's not like you
get like some 30 minute long segment
where like nothing happens right there's
a great balance in there and the not
only that the detective work is really
cool the way that bruce handles being a
detective because he's not fully
polished actually enhances it because
it's one of those things where you feel
like you're figuring it out as he's
figuring it out as opposed to it being
simply being like okay well the riddler
left us this clue boom answer right i
mean you do get that a few times but
it's like the overarching plot what's
actually going on here there's
incredible twists and turns over the
course of this those of you guys who
have been reading comics
if you remember like the new like those
guys who read batman comics i can say
this because the general audience won't
understand this for those of you guys
who read comics do you remember back
with like the new 52 and the whole live
the whole thing that went on with like
thomas and martha wayne there's a lot of
that in there uh it's really really cool
right it's really really phenomenal i
love what's going on with with the whole
story as a whole and then there's the
riddler let's talk about the riddler the
riddler
was
phenomenal he's one of the best comic
book villains that i have seen
in
so long he just like like here's the
thing he crushed the marvel cinematic
universe villain trope like he's more
interesting than any villain you've ever
seen in the marvel cinematic universe
it's just that's why i keep saying man
like the mcu if they don't stop killing
their villains people are going to pass
them up because being able to create
compelling comic book movies that focus
on heroes isn't hard being able to
create compelling comic book movies that
focus on heroes and have a compelling
villain that's the tough thing and
people are working on doing it sony's
doing it warner brothers is doing it the
marvel cinematic universe is not and so
if they keep on this role of like
killing off all the major villains
because it's like well the story is
focused on the heroes they're going to
fall behind man and after watching this
movie i mean that's an argument you
could kind of make you know like i mean
i guess maybe like and like the joker
was like the only real evidence you had
to support that claim coming out of this
movie the riddler's phenomenal the real
the riddler's great and here's the thing
he doesn't look like a goof right he's
not walking around like jim carrey's
riddler where he's got like the red flat
top and he's got like the question marks
on his pants you know whittle me this
you know it's never going to heal if you
don't stop picking you know you don't
get any of that stuff right like this
guy is serious and he is dark and he is
brutal and just and here here's here's
the crazy thing right here here's here's
what's this is this is something that i
want to know from you guys uh assuming
that you watch this after the movie i
don't know how many people are going to
watch this after they've seen the movie
i don't know why you'd watch a spoiler
free review after you've seen the movie
but uh for those of you guys who have
seen it already and are watching this
let me know how you think the riddler
compares to heath ledger's joker because
i'm going to be honest with you guys
i think he's more interesting the joker
had more character development i will
certainly give him that right heath
ledger's joker had a lot more character
development than the riddler does but i
found the riddler to be a lot more
complex and a lot more interesting and a
lot darker than heath ledger's joke you
dark man like he was
he was dark right just ridiculously dark
uh yeah it was it was the the movie the
movie was phenomenal do i think it's the
best comic book movie i've ever seen no
but it's certainly in my top five right
it's definitely in my top five uh but
like i said if you guys saw the joker it
feels so much like the joker movie the
tone and the feeling the kind of like
tangible grittiness it feels like the
joker movie it is great now having said
all that this is one thing that i will
say to you guys about what they're
potentially setting up and we'll cover
this in a separate video but the post is
not really post credit scene kind of a
post credit scene the ending of the
movie they're setting up for a comic
book story arc that happened in the
batman comics
within the last three years pretty sure
they are uh doesn't really say a whole
lot lots happened with batman in the
last three years but they're basically
setting up for that story arc and i am
very excited to see what direction it
goes in uh but the movie's great it's
it's it's yeah it's great so anyway
we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace